Un troisième élément est constitué des réseaux locomoteurs spinaux.
Ce sont des circuits très intéressants dans la moelle épinière des vertébrés,
qui peuvent générer de manière autonome
des activations rythmiques très coordonnées
alors qu'ils ne reçoivent que des informations très simples.
Ces informations venant de modulation descendante des parties hautes du cerveaux
comme le cortex moteur, le cervelet, les ganglions de la base,
vont toutes moduler l'activité de la moelle épinière
lorsque nous bougeons.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est à quel point un tout petit élément,
la moelle épinière, avec le corps,
peut déjà résoudre beaucoup des problèmes de locomotion.
Vous savez que vous pouvez couper la tête d'un poulet
et il peut continuer à courir,
montrant ainsi que juste la partie basse, la moelle épinière et le corps,
peut résoudre une grande part de la locomotion.
Comprendre le fonctionnement est très compliqué,
car enregistrer l'activité de la moelle épinière est très difficile.
Il est plus simple d'implanter des électrodes dans le cortex moteur
que dans la moelle car elle est protégée par les vertèbres.
Spécialement chez les humains.
Une deuxième difficulté est que la locomotion est due
à une interaction très compliquée et très dynamique entre les 4 éléments.
Donc il est très difficile de comprendre le rôle de chacun dans le temps.
C'est là que les robots comme Pleurobots et les modèles mathématiques
peuvent réellement aider.
Donc qu'est-ce que la biorobotique ?
C'est un domaine très dynamique de recherche en robotique
dans lequel les gens veulent s'inspirer des animaux
pour construire des robots de tous les jours
comme des robots d'assistance ou de sauvetage,
ou des robots de terrain.
L'objectif est de s'inspirer des animaux
pour concevoir des robots capables de supporter un terrain compliqué
escalier, montagne, forêt, endroits où les robots ont encore des difficultés
et où les animaux se débrouille mieux.
Le robot peut être un outil scientifique fantastique.
Il existe des projets
dans lesquels on utilise les robots comme outils scientifiques
en neurosciences, en biomécaniques ou en hydrodynamique.
C'est l'objectif de Pleurobot.
Dans mon laboratoire, nous collaborons avec des neurobiologistes
comme Jean-Marie Cabelguen, un neurobiologiste de Bordeaux,
et nous voulons créer des modèles de moelle épinière
et les valider sur des robots. Ici, nous voulons commencer simple.
Donc au début, on commence avec des animaux simples
comme les lamproies, des poissons très primitifs,
et, graduellement, on passe à une locomotion plus complexe,
comme chez les salamandres, les chats, les humains, et les mammifères.
Un robot devient un outil intéressant
pour valider nos modèles.
Pour moi, Pleurobot est comme un rêve devenu réalité.
Il y a environ 20 ans, je travaillais déjà sur ordinateur
pour créer des simulations de locomotion de lamproie et salamandre
pour ma thèse.
Mais j'ai toujours su que mes simulations n'étaient que des approximations.
Simuler la physique de l'eau, de la vase ou de terrain complexe,
c'est très compliqué de simuler tout ça correctement sur ordinateur.
Pourquoi ne pas avoir un vrai robot et de vraies lois physiques ?
Parmi tous ces animaux, l'un de mes favoris est la salamandre.
Si vous vous demandez pourquoi, c'est parce qu'en tant qu'amphibien,
c'est un animal clé d'un point de vue de l'évolution.
Il crée un lien parfait entre la nage
que vous pouvez retrouver chez les anguilles et poissons,
et la locomotion quadrupède,
comme chez les mammifères, les chats et les humains.
En fait, la salamandre est très proche des premiers vertébrés terrestres,
elle est presque un fossile vivant qui nous donne accès à nos ancêtres,
l'ancêtre de tous les tétrapodes terrestres.
La salamandre nage en faisant la nage de l'anguille,
elle utilise une jolie vague d'activité musculaire depuis la tête jusqu'à la queue
Si vous posez la salamandre sur le sol,
elle change pour ce qu'on appelle le trot.
Dans ce cas, vous avez une activation périodique des membres,
qui sont très bien coordonnés avec la vague d'ondulation du corps.
C'est exactement le déplacement que vous pouvez voir ici chez Pleurobot.
Une chose très surprenante et en fait fascinante,
c'est que tout cela peut être généré juste par la moelle épinière et le corps.
Donc si vous prenez une salamandre décérébrée,
ce n'est pas très joli, vous lui retirez la tête,
et que vous stimulez électriquement la moelle épinière,
à un niveau faible de stimulation, cela induit un déplacement de marche.
Si vous stimulez un peu plus, le déplacement s'accélère.
A un moment, vous atteignez un seuil
et l'animal passe automatiquement à la nage. C'est incroyable !
En changeant seulement la stimulation,
comme si vous pressiez la pédale d'accélérateur
de la modulation descendante de votre moelle épinière,
on crée un passage total entre 2 déplacements très différents.
La même chose est observée chez le chat
En stimulant la moelle épinière d'un chat,
vous pouvez passer de la marche, au trot et au gallop.
Ou chez les oiseaux, vous pouvez le faire passer de la marche
avec un faible niveau de stimulation,
au battement d'ailes avec un haut niveau de stimulation.
Cela montre réellement que la moelle épinière
est un contrôle de locomotion très sophistiqué.
Nous étudions la locomotion de la salamandre en détails
et avons accès à une machine d'enregistrement radiographique
du Professeur Martin Fischer à l'Université Jena en Allemagne.
Grâce à ça, vous avez une incroyable machine
pour enregistrer le mouvement avec beaucoup de détails.
C'est ce que nous avons fait.
Nous avons donc compris quels os étaient importants pour nous
et nous avons récupéré leur mouvement en 3D.
Nous avons créé une base de données de mouvements
sur la terre et dans l'eau,
pour créer une base de données complètes des comportements moteurs
qu'un vrai animal peut utiliser.
Notre travail consiste à reproduire ça dans notre robot.
On a utilisé un processus d'optimisation pour trouver
la bonne structure, où placer les moteurs, comment les connecter ensemble
pour reproduire ces mouvements aussi bien que possible.
Et c'est ainsi que Pleurobot est venu au monde.
Regardons à quel point il est proche du vrai animal.
Ce que vous voyez ici est presque une comparaison directe
entre la marche du vrai animal et celle de Pleurobot.
Vous pouvez voir que nous avez presque une reproduction parfaite de la marche.
Si vous allez en arrière lentement, vous pouvez le voir encore mieux.
Mais encore mieux, on peut reproduire la nage.
Pour ça, on a une combinaison étanche que l'on met au robot
(Rires)
ensuite on peut aller dans l'eau et commencer à reproduire la nage.
Nous étions extrêmement contents car c'était difficile.
La physique d'interaction est compliquée.
Notre robot est beaucoup plus grand qu'un petit animal
donc nous avons du faire un redimensionnement dynamique
pour garantir les mêmes interactions physiques.
Mais à la fin, nous avons une association très proche,
et nous en sommes extrêmement contents.
Regardons maintenant la moelle épinière.
Ce que nous avons fait avec Jean-Marie Cabelguen,
c'est modéliser les circuits de la moelle épinière.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que la salamandre
a gardé un circuit très primitif, très similaire de celui de la lamproie,
ce poisson primitif qui ressemble à une anguille
Il semble que durant son évolution, de nouveaux oscillateurs neuronaux
ont été ajoutés pour contrôler les membres pour produire la locomotion des jambes.
Nous savons où ceux-ci se situent,
mais nous avons créé un modèle mathématique
pour voir comment ils devraient être couplés
pour permettre la transition entre 2 déplacements très différents.
Nous avons testé cela sur un robot. Voilà ce que ça donne.
Ce que vous voyez ici est une version antérieure de Pleurobot
qui est entièrement contrôlée par notre modèle de moelle épinière
programmé sur le robot.
Et la seule chose que nous faisons est d'envoyer au robot via une télécommande
les 2 signaux descendants qu'il devrait normalement recevoir
de la part supérieure du cerveau.
Ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'en jouant avec ces signaux
on peut contrôler vitesse, direction et type de déplacements.
Par exemple, quand nous stimulons à faible niveau, nous avons de la marche,
et à un certain point, si nous stimulons plus,
très rapidement on passe à la nage.
Et finalement, on peut faire des virages
en stimulant un peu plus un côté de la moelle épinière que l'autre.
Je pense que c'est magnifique
comment la nature a distribué le contrôle
pour donner beaucoup de responsabilités à la moelle épinière
afin que la partie haute du cerveau n'ait pas besoin de gérer chaque muscle.
Elle a juste à penser à la modulation à un niveau global
et c'est réellement à la moelle épinière de coordonner tous les muscles.
Maintenant passons à la locomotion du chat et à l'importance de la biomécanique.
Ceci est un autre projet
pour lequel nous étudions les biomécaniques du chat.
Nous voulions voir combien la morphologie aide la locomotion.
Et nous avons trouvé 3 propriétés ou critères importants des jambes.
Le premier est que la jambe du chat
ressemble plus ou moins à un structure du style pantographe.
Un pantographe est une structure mécanique
qui garde les segments supérieur et inférieur toujours parallèles.
Donc un simple système géométrique qui coordonne un peu
le mouvement interne des segments.
Une deuxième propriété des membres du chat est sa légèreté.
La plupart des muscles sont dans le tronc, ce qui est une bonne idée car,
les membres ont alors une faible inertie, et peuvent bouger très rapidement.
La dernière propriété importante est ce comportement très élastique du membre
afin de pouvoir supporter les impacts et forces.
Et c'est comme cela que nous avons conçu Cheetah-Cub.
Invitons maintenant Cheetah-Cub sur scène.
Voici Peter Eckert qui fait sa thèse sur ce robot.
Ce robot est très mignon. Il ressemble un peu à un jouet
mais il est utilisé comme outil scientifique
pour comprendre les propriétés de la jambe des chats.
Vous pouvez voir que c'est très similaire, très léger,
et aussi très élastique.
Donc vous pouvez facilement appuyer dessus et il ne cassera pas.
En fait, il va juste sauter.
Et cette propriété d'élasticité est très importante.
Vous pouvez voir un peu des propriétés
de ces trois segments de la jambe en pantographe.
Ce déplacement plutôt dynamique
est obtenu purement en boucle ouverte,
ce qui veut dire pas de capteurs, pas de boucles de capteurs complexes.
C'est intéressant parce que cela veut dire
que la mécanique stabilise déjà ce déplacement plutôt rapide
et que les bonnes mécaniques simplifient déjà la locomotion.
A tel point que l'on peut perturber un peu la locomotion,
comme vous le verrez dans la prochaine video,
où par exemple on fait des exercices, où le robot descend une marche,
et le robot ne va pas tomber, ce qui nous a surpris.
Voici une petite perturbation.
Je m'attendais à ce que le robot tombe immédiatement,
car il n'y a pas de capteurs, ni de boucle de retour rapide.
Mais non, la mécanique stabilise le déplacement
et le robot ne tombe pas.
Si la marche est plus haute, et qu'il y a des obstacles,
vous avez besoin des boucles de capteurs et réflexes et tout.
L'important, c'est que pour une petite perturbation
les mécaniques suffisent.
Je pense que c'est un message très important
de la biomécanique et robotique à la neuroscience,
de dire: « Ne sous-estime pas à quel point le corps aide déjà à la locomotion ».
Maintenant, quel est le lien avec la locomotion humaine ?
Clairement, la locomotion humaine est plus compliquée
que celles du chat et de la salamandre.
Mais en même temps, le système nerveux des humains est très similaire
de celui des autres vertébrés.
Tout particulièrement, la moelle épinière est aussi
le contrôle-clé de la locomotion chez les humains.
C'est pourquoi, une lésion de la moelle épinière a des effets dramatiques.
La personne peut devenir paraplégique ou tétraplégique.
Tout ça parce que le cerveau perd la communication avec la moelle épinière.
Il perd la modulation descendante
pour initier et moduler la locomotion.
Donc un objectif important de la neuroprosthétique
est de pouvoir réactiver la communication
en utilisant des stimulations électriques et chimiques.
Plusieurs équipes à travers le monde recherchent exactement ça,
et particulièrement à EPFL,
mes collègues Grégoire Courtine et Silvestro Micera,
avec qui je travaille.
Mais pour faire cela correctement, il est important de comprendre
comment la moelle épinière fonctionne,
comment elle interagit avec le corps,
et comment le cerveau communique avec la moelle épinière.
C'est là que les robots et modèles que je vous ai présentés aujourd'hui
vont, avec un peu de chance, jouer un rôle-clé
pour atteindre ces objectifs si importants.
Merci
(Applaudissement)
Bruno Giussani: Auke, j'ai vu dans ton laboratoire d'autres robots
qui font des choses comme nager dans la pollution,
et mesurer la pollution en nageant.
Mais pour celui-ci,
tu as mentionné dans ton discours un projet secondaire,
le sauvetage,
et il a une caméra sur le museau.
Auke Ijspeert: Absolument.
Nous avons plusieurs projects secondaires
dans lesquels nous aimerions utiliser les robots pour l'aide au sauvetage,
donc ce robot est en train de te voir.
Le rêve ultime c'est que, si on a une situation difficile
comme un immeuble effondré or innondé, et qu'il est très dangereux d'envoyer
une équipe de sauvetage ou même des chiens de sauvetage,
pourquoi ne pas envoyer un robot qui peut ramper, nager, marcher,
équipé d'une caméra pour inspecter, identifier des survivants,
et potentiellement créer un moyen de communication.
BG: En supposant que les survivants ne soient pas effrayés par ça.
AI: Oui, nous devrions probablement changer un peu son apparence
car pour l'instant, un survivant pourrait avoir une crise cardiaque
juste en se demandant si ce truc veut le manger.
Mais en changeant son apparence et en le rendant plus robuste,
je suis sur que l'on peut en faire un bon outils.
BG: Merci à toi et ton équipe